hi welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and as we imagine what
great things are over Marvel's Horizon
starving us out making me beg we should
remember there's still Spider-Man 4 out
there and no lock villain yet this video
is sponsored by Squarespace the
all-in-one platform that makes launching
your own website of Breeze the cosmic
Circle has sparked the internet Rumor
Mill back up with some alleged
breadcrumbs that this villain might be
one we've never seen before in live
action and let me tell you we've seen a
lot a lot so keep your pants on and
remember where we are in the MCU right
now our heroes are all over the place
the world separated by teams and before
we see the Fantastic 4 or Deadpool on
Disney plus we're seeing the defender
Saga being updated currently Marvel
literally created a new Banner to
highlight on the ground heroes and
villains that doesn't require homework
so what Spider-Man villains have we not
seen before that also fits currently
with what's happening in the MCU what
would that story look like well in this
video I'm going to tell you exactly what
that story will look like and give you
my favorite Spider-Man picks we should
get but first be sure to check out nerd
rot. shop to check out the latest and
greatest in new rockstars merch you can
grab our shirt featuring the best bub
Deadpool and Wolverine or maybe our
latest shirt featuring Madam web with
the greatest line from any movie trailer
in history grabbing some Merd From Nerd
r. shop is the best way to support the
channel and all the work we do here at
new rock stars okay now let's get into
the actual meat of it all so if the
rumor is true Let's cross off every live
action villain we've seen and I'm
talking about doov Green Goblin Rhino
evil hary Electro Sandman venom lizard
Mysterio vulture you know you know you
know them I'm not taking off the
villains we haven't seen like villain
yet because those are little Marvel gold
nuggets for any movie to come back and
resurrect into a new story line or build
off that we saw last now the easiest
Target we know kingpin's already here
and a great Spider-Man villain
especially now seeing us Peter has no
family leverage anymore and I know it's
horrible to think about but kingpin's
first strategy is to hit them where it
really hurts and Peter has no one unless
of course Kingpin finds MJ and Ned but
as of right now he doesn't know they are
connected to Peter so this man is like
FIS Kryptonite bonus the rekindle lean
we could see between Matt and Peter
would be great even if Matt doesn't
really remember why he represented Peter
in the first place that story is also
easy to follow as well Kingpin becomes
becomes mayor and Born Again Matt tries
to take on Kingpin during the blip jump
back to the present mayor Kingpin
storyline and the numerous attempts at
dethroning him by the Defenders to no
Prevail Kingpin doesn't work alone he
has goons and a squad of horrible people
so we'll likely get glimpses of his
teams like he had in into the
spiderverse and those are the New York
base thugs we love like Tombstone and
I'll call this villain pitch May Kingpin
in the Entourage oh yeah I could see
Tombstone being the new villain for
Spider-Man in the fourth movie because
Tombstone lived a life that was like
kind of close to fist but his job was
usually as the enforcer so this would be
a great time to replace F's old one my
Lopez we saw Tombstone and into the
spiderverse in the Insomniac games but
not yet liveaction and this guy can be
as violent and ruthless as Kingpin if
mayor Fisk storyline triumphs and he
initiates a campaign hunting Vigilantes
that would include Spider-Man if he's
back on his it would make sense
after the events of Spider-Man 3 Peter's
now studying for his GED and doing lower
Stakes heroic since the big hero
stuff kind of led to you know horrible
things happening additionally in Eko
Maya blew up the warehouse in a very
terrorist likee Manner and that
shouldn't be left unnoticed X returning
to these big or small events with
leftovers like how Loki's attack
inspired cap bishop or Baron Zemo being
affected by Ultron and sovia creating a
solid villain in himself the bomb
released in echko could be the welcoming
of Tombstone who always had that look
but the diox 3 was what gave him his
powers the train car was labeled d9x if
9 is divisible by three we hold the io
we've got d9x baby the case holding the
homemade bomb could have released
chemicals when mixed with whatever else
was in that warehouse delivering
Tombstone his powers also that warehouse
isn't far off in looks from the insomnia
games where Peter found diox 3 so a
world where Tombstone is sent to fight
Spider-Man in his fourth lower Stakes
movie makes sense but if we're staying
in that New York Thug activity so does
Hammerhead Hammerhead to me feels like
the mober version to Kingpin and we
haven't seen him one bit though we get
teases and Echo that other people are
out there trying to compete with Fisk
one of those people would absolutely be
Hammerhead Hammerhead even Rose to more
power in the New York streets after
Kingpin was in prison or just laying low
and was almost killed by one of
kingpin's Agents Daredevil and The
Punisher stopped him from taking more of
kingpin's factions at one point also in
the comics the internet has speculated
this being the best time during mayor
Kingpin Ste down from crime and steep
into politics to take over the
underground crime Rings since the throne
is now open so Spider-Man 4 could be
Kingpin running for May and the
competitive crime Rings all trying to
take over New York because Spider-Man
versus Hammerhead possibly Tombstone and
other New York crime mobs that's that's
just impossible he'll have to call for
help not trying to tie this back to Ekko
but it would also make sense that Ekko
sending that bomb was a message to
everyone in New York like she said that
there's a new person trying to take on
Kingpin and the other New York crime are
taking that as a major tip that Kingpin
is slipping or they should try to take
him down again so Hammerhead with his
big guns and fake Italian accent would
be fun to see especially since our only
real mob guy is Kingpin and we know
there's so many out there if you're a
new year new you kind of person and an
online kind of person then it's really a
new year new URL if you're looking to
get the most out of your site you should
check out Squarespace Squarespace is an
all-in-one platform that provides you
with everything you need to know to do
whatever you need with your website
Squarespace has templates and designs
for pretty much everything so whether
you're making your very first website or
sprucing up one for the new year using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products and save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even a service
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business just
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com neww rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain another big and people want to
see and could still work with the May
fist storyline a scorpion now he had a
small little appearance in Spider-Man
Homecoming in prison we know Kingpin
went to Rikers and I don't know exactly
where Adrien tombs and Scorpion are but
they both could be in the same prison
for Bad Boys with Kingpin one of my
favorite takeaways in Spider-Man 2 and
the Insomniac Games is Peter Parker's
biggest fear is all the men put in
prison escaping and kingpin's out of
prison somehow so we could play
Spider-Man 4 with scorpion being
enlisted by Kingpin to take out
Vigilantes or scorpion could escape
prison and be ready with other convicts
to go after Spider-Man which could
traumatize our boy because he couldn't
take them all on by himself even into
the spiderverse he had a team my
favorite in this villain could go both
ways like a hardcore villain or like a
good guy working along fist during his
political campaign and then turn into a
major villain is Mr negative Mr negative
AKA Martin Lee is a super rich
philanthropist so he looks great on
paper just you know not to me because I
hate billionaires he owns a soup kitchen
Feast which we see in no way home and
gives to the needy because he's such a
great guy but he's also living a double
life one as Martin Lee and another as Mr
negative he was just a crime B and
horrible person he even gotone into
politics in the comics and folks fought
to be endorsed by him because he had so
much sway over the people back to no way
home we saw Aunt May voner at Feast to
help people and in her passing I can see
Peter taking that statement to heart and
feeling close to May and Away helping at
the nonprofit he's also alone and I bet
there he meets sweet old Martin Lee and
he says swell guy major charitable
helper for the community and then he's
endorsing Wilson Fisk the monster of New
York well maybe he doesn't know Wilson
Fisk is a bad uh oh he is a bad guy and
so is Martin Lee and feast is a front
for his horrible engagements in
underground crime activi so it's up to
Peter to stop him and once he does at
the end of Spider-Man 4 that sets off
Kingpin who sends other people after
Spider-Man though luckily he has the
Defenders backing him up Martin Le can
have a ton of different story lines that
lead to different outcomes in the video
games he had a pretty great heel turn
eventually helping and supporting miles
after killing his father still love the
storyline of a really rich
philanthropist doing horrible
behind closed doors like every Super
Rich philanthropist they say they want
to get dark in the MCU then make it dark
this story line also brings attention to
Peter's emotions after the events of no
way home he's Alone lost his family
friends and educated I bet he feels
guilty and it's probably eating him up
inside so I want to see my boy find some
sort of Outlet or new friends to help
him which he can find in the Defenders
who have all lost something or even just
helping the community again seeing that
friendly neighborhood Spider-Man that we
all used to love this would be a great
introduction to another villain I would
love to see black cat I just love black
cat who does it she's cool as hell if MJ
and Peter are no longer together maybe
this is his way of moving on and I will
probably be murdered for saying that on
camera which is okay you know I'm I'm
just theorizing regardless black cat has
made many famed appearances over
Spider-Man 's career but not in the
liveaction sense so this is all just
wishful thinking would she be the main
villain of Spider-Man 4 probably not but
be introduced possibly I mentioned the
mental stress Peter's probably left with
and black cat might be a great friend in
those regards and they are both Heroes
and can defend themselves they'll never
have to worry about losing another
person the story for black cat would
also align with the Wilson Fisk
storyline black cat could be a burglar
working for Wilson Fisk I'm sure Maya
wasn't the only orphan little girl on
his payroll or she could simply work
with her dad Who's involved in
underground crime ring in New York and
then one of the many serpent say Peter
walks in on to save the day actually a
young woman black cat robbing a home
they fight she escapes and like Catwoman
to Batman they see each other and give
friendly advice as light enemies and
it's a dance that turns into a romance
now that's my take because I love enemy
to lover stories but I'm sure Marvel
will try to give her a reason for not
wanting to be a villain one that I think
would be cool but not as crazy would be
Prowler now I think Prowler would be fun
but the direct impact of bringing
Prowler into this world also brings in
miles if we already have Donald Glover
alluding to being Prowler in the first
Spider-Man movie then we see him in a
cross the spiderverse we might as well
start sewing the seeds for miles since
Electro mentioned a one-off line about a
black boy Spider-Man somewhere in New
York good things comeing three so I
expect to see him soon if Prowler
appeared as the villain in Spider-Man 4
it would probably be under the same guys
as into the spiderverse so working
directly for Wilson fist he mentioned
working for Scorpion and homecoming but
he was too crazy and left I could see
sometime after those events he starts
working for Kingpin he's then given the
equipment or he works under another
Crime Boss who's out for kingpin's free
territories after running for Mar so if
Prowler were in Spider-Man 4 and the
villain we'd probably see him working
for Fisk as an enforcer and given his
equipment from Fisk who has a fun new
gadgets in the MCU to be fair I've not
included some villains like null because
I think this is a big villain on its
path in the Sony Marvel Universe it
might be a villain we don't touch as
they're prepping for the beef between
the Symbiotes but after Thor love and
thunder introduced the necro sword and
we have venom recognizing Peter on the
TV in the mid- credit scene of no way
home it feels likely we could be
bridging that relationship between sonyy
and the MCU with null I think my only
hesitation personally is I've seen the
MCU you wipe out massive Gods with a
swift glance and null shouldn't be that
easy to beat null would have to be a
phase villain and I don't see that
coming anytime soon since we're still
gearing up for Fantastic 4 mutants and
figuring out what to do with King
hobgoblins Ned is another character
people want to see return as a villain
luckily since the MCU doesn't go
completely comic book accurate we might
not get to see Hob Goblin Ned I say
luckily because I don't think the story
is quite there yet of someone
brainwashing Ned or even Ned making a
heel turn suddenly I don't think people
want to see an evil Ned the way we saw
an evil Harry I like the story line
better without making that a villain
letting him just go to school and the
loans naturally turning him into one is
just more realistic and Justified I
would like to see Hob Goblin I think
there's a story where after the events
of no way home the millionaires who fund
the scientists of New York find some
lingering evidence of the spell that
wiped everyone's memory of Peter Parker
and rodri Kingsley the dangerous
millionaire becomes enamored and
obsessed with what he knows of the Green
Goblin and becomes the Hobgoblin this
would still feed into the Wilson Fisk
May storyline as Fisk is the heart and
center of all of this you let me know
who you think will be the ultimate
villain for Spider-Man 4 we know it's
probably Kingpin but Kingpin and New
York have a ton of crime leaders think
outside of the box put Mr negative in
because that's all I want follow me on
Instagram and Twitter Lulu Clemens
follow new rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love check out the break
room and the Deep dive okay I'll see you
guys
later